Bonjour bonjour comment ça va ? Vous avez vu on dirait
un basketteur ! Un basketteur d'1m20
mais un basketteur quand même ! Aujourd'hui on va
parler de quoi ? Bah on va parler des commentaires
Youtube ! Il y a presque un mois on faisait
une vidéo qui s'appelait le fléau de Youtube
où on parlait de l'espace commentaire Youtube qui
était totalement pollué par diverses
choses on va pas revenir là-dessus
...
*souvenirs de la vidéo*
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH !!!!!
Ca suffit ! Eh bien aujourd'hui nous allons voir ensemble si ça a marché
si l'espace commentaire est redevenu un espace cool ! Sommes-nous dans une
nouvelle ère dans une sixième
république ? C'est maintenant que ça commence !
Envoyez le Jingle
UNE NOUVELLE ÈRE DES COMMENTAIRES
Allez c'est partie on va lire tout ça et j'espère ne pas voir de "Like" de "Aime si tu
bidule" ç...ça dégage hein ! Mais j'ai eu des
échos et apparemment c'est bien mieux qu'avant
Regardons tout de suite la dernière vidéo
"Squeezie t'as rien respecté, t'as mis ton polo dans ton short, en plus t'as laissé l'étiquette d'achat"
T'as quoi contre les gens qui mettent les choses dans leurs jeans ?
HEIIN ! T'aimes pas les années 80 mon pote ?
Ah ça fait mal ... Squeezie y a la souris sur l'écran
c'est vrai ceci est extrêmement  S...
Ohla oh la mindfuck
Mindfuck ! Double souris dans la vidéo mais qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ? J'avoue des fois je ne fais pas attention et  le logiciel
Capture le curseur ce qui vous stresse énormément comme actuel...
tu fais exprès de garder les étiquettes sur
les vêtements ou tu oublies dans toutes
les vidéos, c'est pour se faire
rembourser après ! alors déjà déjà
que ça soit clair !
J'ai l'air de l'avoir rendu au magasin ce tee shirt ? NAN ! Pourquoi je fais ça on va élucider ce mystère tout de suite
Les casquettes américaines
la mode c'est quoi c'est quoi
c'est la mode les gars
C'EST LA MODE ! EH BAH POURQUOI LE POLO A 4€ CHEZ DECATHLON ON NE FERAIT PAS PAREIL ?
c'est les inégalités ça m'énerve ! c'est juste
la mode les gars désolé si vous êtes pas
à la mode désolé
il a acheté une tenue pour UNE SEULE VIDEO PUTAIN
Ohla ohlaaa j'suis un professionel de ping pong j'avais déjà une tenue, garçon
Et j'peux te dire que j'ai gagné les plus grands championnats du monde dans cette tenue
Mais Squeezie comment TU CONNAIS LA POSITION GRENOUILLE
C'EST UNE TECHNIQUE LEGENDAIRE ENSEIGNEE A NOS ANCÊTRES QUI N'A DES LORS JAMAIS ÉTÉ RÉVÉLÉE ... tu commences à me faire peur Squeezie
Wesh maggle ! DES BARRES
aller on fait un ping pong ! un coup droit avec la main gauche ... d'accord Squeezie
MALAISE TV
J'tenvoie ce screen il est pour toi mets le dans une compil je sais pas
Mais un coup droit mon gars c'est quand c'est la paume de la main
qui envoie la balle c'est pas un coup
droit puisque tu l'envoie
OHHH MEEEC
Oh c'est drôle oh franchement
c'est mignon ça fait penser à moi
jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans qui pensait
que on disait cire humaine et pas cérumen
J'suis sur je viens de l'apprendre à certain d'entre vous faites pas genre
Putain tes bras sont aussi gros que tes cuisses MDR
ça te fais rire ... ça te fais rire
Il doit prendre ça pour un compliment ?
mdrr
ça te fait rire ... on dirait un tee shirt d'employé non ?
Mec c'est ce que je me disais ! ATTENDS
J'crois qu'en vrai mec c'est le tee shirt des gens qui travaillent au mcdo
Voilà nan ça c'est pas les gens qui travaillent au mcdo
comment en tapant gens qui travaillent au mcdo je tombe sur ça ! c'est n'importe quoi
j'irai plus souvent au mcdo moi à ce moment là ! attends tenue fast food
Oh non ! Un big mac et une grande frite ?
Oh noooooon
Bon j'avoue j'ai du me gourer au décathlon, j'ai du aller au rayon fast food ... qui valide cette blague ?
personne
Bahh alors où est passé le "YO TOUT LE MONDE C'EST SQUEEZIE !"
Bah j'lai pris, j'lai pris comme ça je l'ai posé là
MISSILE !
JUSTIN BIEBER
MISSILE
ELECTRICITÉ
GAZ
EXPLOSION
EXPLOSION EXPLOSION SIONSIONsiOSJSNjkjs
Squeezie a pris de la barbe mais il a perdu des cheveux
Oh non c'est mon coiffeur qui est en train d'appeler
Merde désolé j'ai mal posé la prothèse
du coup tu t'es fait griller
NAN je ne veux pas de calvitie ! c'est vrai attends j'ai vraiment perdu des cheveux ?
Bon j'avoue BON STARFOULLAH j'vais dire ce que tout le monde dit : eh depuis que je suis né j'ai ça
Mais est-ce que quelque part ce n'est pas une preuve de virilité ?
non ! Je commente cette vidéo alors que Lucas ne lis pas les commentaires
bah détrompe toi je les lis depuis que j'ai fais la vidéo sur le fléau de youtube fin je lis ce qui sont en top donc les
100 premiers et ça me fait méga
plaisir vraiment ça m'avait manqué
Putain ! vous m'aviez manqué
Ouahh t'es tellement beau et viril !
Dark robinet
Dark robinet faut qu'on parle j'ai
des doutes sur ta sincérité
Euh sinon on en parle que dans la description le jeu est pong ? ... quoi ?
YOUTUBE ! Youtube prenez votre robot là vous lui mettez des petites claques comme ça ! ARRETE DE STRIKER LES GENS QUI UTILISENT DU MAITRE GIMS
ARRETE DE TE GOURER DANS LA DETECTION DES JEUX
alors passons à la vidéo ce jeu explose ton
cerveau ah souplesse niveau angle droit
voilà ! au début j'croyais qu'il parlait de l'écho genre de sa voix avec un truc qui fonctionnait avec son micro mais je ne comprenais pas trop
bah nan un écho de soi-même
pourquoi je rentre dans ce débat qu'est-ce qu'il m'arrive ?
depuis quand Squeezie est plus intelligent que nous ? qui a compris ce jeu de taré
Alors j'suis pas du tout plus intelligent que vous mais en vrai les jeux comme ça un petit peu compliqués à cause du
montage des fois c'est beaucoup moins
compréhensible pour vous que pour moi qui
vit le truc vraiment. Vous vous ne voyez qu'une sorte de best of donc vous avez moins
temps pour comprendre en plus y a des cuts
dans un jeu comme ça c'est compliqué
du coup de suivre c'est pour ça que les jeux comme ça qui demandent
un petit peu de réflexion comme echoplex et qui sont gratuits je vous invite à les
télécharger et  à tester vous-même echoplex qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est un mot qui rime avec 'duplex', 'cornflakes'...
Voilà, plus de deux rimes c'était trop compliqué pour moi.
Les rimes au début étaient ... comPLEX
WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Il est chaud Lord Tioko
j'crois que j'ai choppé une rhino à la pgw
qui est le mec parmi vous qui m'a donné sa rhinopharyngite
MONTRE TOI FDP ... je vais bien m'occuper de ton cas
Regardez mon on peut faire de messages audio sur
Youtube
voilà ce qui se passe quand ton commentaire est hors sujet !
Squeezie je t'adore tes putains de vidéos
Oh la violence ...  gros bisous à toi et je
vais te dire que je serai plus grands
que toi normalement l'infirmière du collège
m'a dit que je ferais 1m76 (lol)
moi elle m'avait dit que je ferai 1m85
elle s'est bien trompée
je t'en veux madame dorénavant ... j'ten veux !
j'suis entre le pleur et le baillement
Ah ah non ça baille ! ok on passe à  happy wheels 3d !
Franchement tes blagues sont de mieux en mieux ! mais pas ton orth...
Ton orthographe
GoZe_AngeleS &co
oh comment il m'a devancé ! il m'a
devancé de 17 heures le mec sur ma blague
PUTAIN ! Bien joué
C'est gentil War zgame
Vous devez mais je dis bien vous devez mettre TOUTES les vidéos de Squeezie en vitesse 0.5
Il a l'air bourré mais à un point tel ...
aujourd'hui nous allons ensemble
jouer
on dirait vraiment dit François Hollande ... excellent j'adore tout ce qui est drôle
c'est vrai que jumbo est mort ? Pas du tout il va très très bien il dort toujours
autant il mange toujours autant mais il fait plus de bêtise ! depuis que j'ai montré son vrai visage dans une vidéo
il fait moins de malin hein !
REGARDEZ
Y'avait du lait ! on m'explique ces putain de traces de crocs
Cette fontaine de lait qu'il y avait partout ici !
sa bouffe est posé ici ! ET LA DERNIERE FOIS LE PAQUET IL ETAIT LA !
Tu te reproches quelque chose ?
Comment tu fais pour faire une vidéo tout les deux jours tout en aillannt
Comment tu fais pour faire une vidéo tout les des deux jours j'arrive pas à lire désolé
Un vrai problème analphabétisme là
1:11 ressemblance 100%
Ressemblance avec qui ? Malcolm ? Jesse Pinkman ? acteur américain très beau gosse
UNE CHEVRE ! c'est l'heure du bilan
C'est beau ce que je fais avec ma main ! c'est super beau abonnez vous à sa chaine Youtube
NOOON NE CRÉE PAS DE CHAINE YOUTUBE QUI S'APPELLE LA MAIN ...
Vous êtes une des personnes les plus vues sur le net dans le monde
Bah écoutez comme vous pouvez le voir c'est
vraiment beaucoup mieux qu'avant ça m'amuse de nouveau énormément de lire vos commentaires
et ça me fait super plaisir franchement ça m'avait grave manqué parce que comme je vous ai dis
faire des vidéos voir des vues des
trucs mais jamais voir de vrais messages
des gens des gens qui donnent leurs
avis ou qui ont envie de se marrer avec toi etc ...
Bah c'... bah je me sentais un peu vide
Et là putain je me sens plein ! et c'est grâce à vous je vous remercie vraiment
du coup c'est validé ! c'est validé par la prod c'est validé par Booba c'est validé
par
le comité de validation des
commentaires Youtube et merci beaucoup au gens qui m'avais envoyé
plein plein plein plein de mails suite à ma vidéo le fléau de youtube
pour me dire qu'il y a des
moyens de mettre un modérateur sur sa
chaîne youtube des mecs qui ont le
pouvoir de supprimer les commentaires
tout comme toi du coup y a une petite
armée de modérateurs maintenant qui
rôde dans l'espace commentaires et
qui supprime tout ce qui est hors sujet
First commentaire like etc bah d'ailleurs
vous pouvez maintenant remarquer qu'en bas
de la description des vidéos il ya des
règles voilà à respecter dans l'espace
commentaire j'espère que vous êtes
aussi content que moi de voir cet espace
redevient très très cool ça fait
plaisir putain ça m'avait vraiment manqué et puis comme d'habitude je vous dis quoi ?
A très vite dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé portez-vous bien Ciao tout le monde
clé usb.